I'm Elena and I'm going to talk about
using data for stories which is
something that I have been doing as a
journalist for quite some time now and
this will not be technical i am not a
programmer and the the code you will see
I'm very sad to say will be in Pearl but
and nevertheless I'm thought we start
actually since I've worked many years in
television well I'll start by showing
you the product of sort of what I do
which is a television story it will be
in Swedish but it will have sometimes
I'll try different levers see if
anything works
he comes our shaniqua physical world
upon a gift man who need it is arguable
did 10 verse after the discus community
on but then they done to control over
some particular into something about
what he hit on you inted or local
singers worth it is going to a Border
Collie and the fiends through narrow
road at san Farina Sebastian man making
you sport clubs and is a house drunk
answer from dominica weapon Irving
answer who ashley is so here you have
the Institute for evening to clear an
article in the era of mosca summing it
up in a very poor cousin Ellen children
are creepy and one who you have Russian
him over when the Lance warrior
community in germany until homeless
without in a nice area code talk about a
magician who knows what other we are in
your soul forever many I mean to say
tentative you know different going to
search all together and select new
iphone this is nanotubes and plant
satisfied about her studies class for if
that song has caught a man shall not too
Ortiz takes form legally buttercream
genre would oh poor empty unload on her
plants home on Interphone really didn't
but if on a terry hon hon tommy hunter
lewbert's million less than a bit forum
unfolding and re-interviewed corner some
hairy ian atkinson funda wouldn't plums
colon a manometer experience fish
everything's music feel guilty and we'll
have a would imagine take sugar
recruiters care set up or make distal
disgusting to your bath ornamental tree
top they have an intense do this and
thought the moss on it and build yet
enforce to job ID murder
I am another local community but if it's
rude and hastily chef ever known Ronaldo
you're never on to this was so fun super
one that'll give them some solace and
spiteful FS also pants cognizant una
mentira tea expo negating happy
non-human contact you in toga london and
in learning of dance am clearly not
saving at the order of nature p alike
that's why I'm supposed or can she live
here mmm unable to get its own enmity
eres para world mr de niro and you get
in today to music attention also the
about the region over 60 tone little
more far from my gallery it be instantly
lateral of their food at least we have a
month now passed a little vinegar and
offensive twister ash commence a warning
if to her holding Leah Vaughn + 3 y 0 SS
for poor girl stuff on them and they're
in space for kids I vector can you
finish its mouth it's a perceptive ok
honest I don't work with people they had
had a meeting about its design but
that's all oh please oh come on no
that's not that's not do a repeat on
that ah here we are here we are good
something is wrong
there we go so this is a project that we
did a couple of years ago that is sort
of a explanation of what I think data
journalism is it is a online database
with 80,000 places around Sweden and
that we have built sort of an online
service on that way you can go and look
for your for your own where you're where
you live with myself and it's built on a
database that comes from the 21 regions
of Sweden and everybody but one actually
gave it to me in Excel we plotted this
as you see it has a couple of years
because nobody uses Google Maps anymore
but at that time everybody used google
maps and you can of course by using this
service this site go in and look at how
does it look it out where I live and we
took every single thing that was in the
database in and put it in the database
put it online but we also did call out
if you know anything about this place
please email us if you want to know more
about this place we also put in an
instruction how you make a Freedom of
Information request yourself to ask for
more information but this place so we
try to help the public in sort of
getting more information if they
suddenly realize that wait a minute I
live next door to this glass factory
that has a lot of that has been has a
lot of pollution in between it and but
we didn't go there we didn't stop by
just putting everything out there
because that is not journalism that is
just you know reporting this is the
areas of drinking water protected
drinking water and this is the
contaminated places and then of course
we did we merge them together we found
the 86 places that you heard about in
this and then we could do reporting on
that and once we found them we of course
started doing sort of ordinary
journalistic reporting we asked for
documents for these places we talked to
experts we talked to locals we went out
there and did
the story so it's just but instead of
looking at thousand places we had these
86 that we could look at and choose from
so we were much more defined in what we
were doing and we could do the story
about the arsenic at the kids where the
kids went swimming but at that time I
also work for Swedish television that
has a number of regional offices just as
the BBC we have a lot number of regional
offices room Sweden so I could send out
parts of the database to each of our
regional office and each of them could
do stories out from their local
perspective so this is just a few of all
the stories that we did out of that
database which means that it also gave
us you know a lot of coverage of this so
for me data journalism is two things
basically I use data to analyze and then
I can also present my results and I can
you know do ordinary things sorting
grouping counting and then of course
doing interacting databases and maps but
it's very important for me that the
methods that I learn is the method to
reach the goal I have a journalistic
problem that I needs to be solved and I
might have to learn technical method to
solve that problem and I'm a little bit
allergic to the word it used to be
called computer system reporting and I'm
sort of or data journalism as it is as
if it's something else than journalism
but we never talk about telephone
assisted German reporting or pen and
paper I mean that our tools and i would
think that computers are or data methods
so data science is another tool for us
to have in our toolbox and for me all my
i would say that most of my bosses had
swedish television and most of my bosses
at the Guardian thinks that data
journalism has to do with numbers oh
she's really good at math they say I
actually suck at math ask my old math
teacher
for me it's the details finding that
detail that gives the story a few years
back it's almost it's five years now I
was at a gathering at one of the Swedish
sort of sweet journalistic groups and
one of the big bosses in Swedish
journalism stepped up and we were
talking at that time about the WikiLeaks
Iraq database and he said wow it's
meaningless why should generalists even
bother with that kind of material it's
390,000 documents there's no journalist
in the world who can read all this and I
was a little shy at that time so i
should have what I should have done was
to stand up and say well moths but
that's that was his name it depends on
how we do it I just did it and when I
showed this picture for journalists they
get really excited for you this is you
know not so exciting I can just you know
select the documents that has that is
about Sweden and by doing that instead
of looking at 390,000 documents I look
at 57 documents and everybody can read
57 documents so with with those
documents we did a lot of stories we did
stories about the Swedish weapons that
were mentioned in the Iraq database but
this is my favorite story this is the
28,000 658 document or actually row in
that database because it was a database
and this is a story about a Swedish
citizen with Iranian background who got
caught in a in a checkpoint and thrown
in jail in Baghdad and we could find him
there was his name was print printed we
could find him working at now working at
a gas station in in Gothenburg in Sweden
and he could tell his story and sorry
and he could tell his story to us and we
could sort of tell the story behind the
document and that is the detail in that
that's the needle in the haystack
another thing when it comes to data
journalism is different things simple
analysis for instance the horrible
events that happen in Charleston
at just this week we were we wanted to
tell the story and explain the story of
course so what we did was that we went
to the United States statistical Bureau
Census Bureau and they have amazing
statistics they have the racial profiles
of every block in the US so I could go
there I could download the data for
Charleston I could get the the database
I could make a very very simple
calculation which calculated the
percentage of whites and black and
American Indian and so on for each block
and the D equals series just because I
don't want division by zero when there's
no people in that you know in some of
the blocks there were no people and we
could do a story the next day this
product this was this was on the web a
couple of during the afternoon which had
different explanations but also had this
map describing how the racial profile
was and how it actually had changed over
the years and if we do a little bit more
complicated one of the big issues when
you're doing data journalism is actually
extracting the data and cleaning the
data I think I spend with a story at
least sixty percent of my time getting
the data into a format that I can
actually then analyze it with and this
is a story I did previous this year
where a reporter came to me and said I
want to look at this organization this
I'm an American organization that helps
people donate money to right-wing or not
right wing because that sounds like
they're not since they're not like sort
of conservative organizations among
those a lot of climate among those a lot
of organizations that deny climate
change or at least questions climate
change in different
so this is a tax form from the suite
from the US tax authorities it's a PDF
it's a picture PDF which means that it
has it doesn't have I have I have to OCR
it before I can do anything with it and
within that there's pages and pages of
tables of the organizations that this
organization is giving to and what I
have to do is OCR it when you also it
looks like that not exactly pretty I
have to turn it into something I can use
and you can see that i also have to code
the organization's you see that the OCR
on the top the first row can read maybe
to code it so that i get the names
standardized and then once i'm here this
took me a week once i'm here it's very
easy to do all the summing and could see
how much of the money that they spent
were actually spent on organizations
that question climate change and this is
also thing I work together with
reporters that's my job I work together
with reporters to help them tell the
story in that data drive a story I can't
give them you know and a huge excel file
they all crunch and don't anything so my
job is also to make this as accessible
as possible so hence the sort of pretty
thing here saying that this is this is
what i found this is the highest
organizations this is the little errors
that i found in it so that so that they
know and can sort of say okay we'll live
with the fact that we have a difference
in the total amount that they said and
the total amount that i calculated of 0
point fifteen percent so then we did
this story that got pretty well received
about the secretive donors that give the
climate change of money you can also use
map for analysis we looked at maps for
presentation but not
maps for analysis this is a story we did
very quickly also this is also a new
story done by on a day where the
Parliament the House of Commons were had
a law in that they were going to decide
on where they want to go and exclude all
a lot of areas from fracking so they
want to exclude the protected areas the
groundwater areas the national parks and
so on so what we did basically is that
we took all the shapefiles of all these
areas put them on top and then on the
top of that we put the areas that were
already approved for fracking and we
could then do the story that forty
percent of the area that was aimed for
fracking was would now to be a band I
think they backed on that law
unfortunately after that but we did this
very quickly if you do no longer
analysis i use programming to do data
this is the European Parliament the
European Parliament votes once or twice
every month and nowadays there are a
website that looks at this but when i
was doing this it wasn't and they
published their votes as PDF or Word
documents and they look like this so you
and they are not pictures actually
though so they're easier to sort of I
don't have to do the OCR for these but
all the last names of all the people no
matter what nationality the
parliamentarian comes from from the
party group so with in here somewhere
he's a sweet and I want to keep track of
this week of the Swedes and how they
voted so this is this is pearl and this
is basically me extracting the data and
checking and and calculating finding all
the people that said yes all the people
that said no and all the people that
abstain their vote and by doing that I
get that into a database
and that has actually both the date but
also the time and it showed that the
time actually made sense when I do the
story I didn't know that when I did the
story to start with but the time
actually made it made a big point so
what I could do this it's sort of look
at all the sweets and also look at how
they were present at the Parliament and
that's when the time made a difference
because I actually found out that some
of them left very early so after twelve
o'clock on a certain day they weren't
sorry they vote in they vote a whole
week that week every month so I could
find out that they they were leaving
very very early and that when there were
many votes left because they had so such
a long time to travel they said and so
we could then do the story I would say
that this is this is an old project that
I still show because I spent three
months on this and it became 240 in a
new segment it became a to 40 minutes
new segment and that was it you could
say that I didn't invest my time very
well and another story also using
programming actually I did recently I
did this this autumn just coming to
Guardian this was my fourth first story
at the Guardian and this was also an
idea from a reporter reporter came to me
and he said I'm using reddit quite a lot
he said and I must admit that I had a
very at that time a very vague idea of
what read it was and but he said I see
that there's a lot of ugly stuff in
there and still it's considered
something that we especially the
Guardian if a story hits reddit we're
really happy because it means that it
gets a lot of views around the world so
I say sometimes that I spent my first
month at the Guardian looking at porn
that's not really true but someone
there's a lot of there's a lot as you
know probably all immune there's a lot
of sites and reddits that are generated
in any kind I found out though that I
could just look
the moderators and I didn't have to look
at the actual pictures this is the
moderators of the very horrible group
called cute female corpses I've actually
been I looked at those pictures they are
it is what it is it is exactly what it
is it's cute female corpses and so what
i did was i extracted all the moderators
and put them into a database and wanted
to find out where were if they were
moderators what were they moderating and
what we could see was that there were
moderators for the really big good
groups sort of say that also moderated
this not so good things so by using as
you saw access and excel and we could
write this story where we looked at
cleaning up the mess behind the behind
read it and what I could find for
instance was the the very big group all
that has pictures that you say all about
also moderates people that moderate that
also moderated drunk girls or people
that moderate earth porn which is
actually not porn things that are called
porn in reddit is usually not porn it
just pretty pictures they also moderate
the beautiful little group called watch
people die so that was a story that also
got a pretty good just to show you that
you can also use it for a little you
know less serious if we talk about
presentation you can do very simple
presentations for instance this is a
database of all the traffic cameras all
the speed cameras around Sweden and that
I got actually from the from the
transportation board in Sweden I just
put them into a map this is tableau and
then I put a reporter I put a reporter
at one of the actually after the
reporter
one of the really high and he could just
stand there and say this is one of the
highest the cameras that catches the
most people and we could do three days
before Christmas we could do we could
publish this map and tell people watch
out on the road this is where the
cameras are and if you look at a little
bit more advanced presentation this is
also project with the red Swedish
television where we want it to look at
youth and crime and as in London or as
in all countries there are suburbs or
areas that have this you know they have
this problem with there's a lot of
there's a lot of crime especially among
the youth but we wanted to see whether
or not that wasn't true in other cities
as well just focusing on monomer which
is in town in southern Sweden and
Stockholm as we do in Sweden maybe not
may not be good so what we got from the
Census Bureau was data on a very small
statistical geographical area so that a
city maybe there's between between 500
and 2000 people in each of those areas
and this is the smallest statistical
area you can use so we got the
population we got the population between
15 and 19 and then we asked how many
that resided in that area was also taken
judged in court and then we could just
calculate the percentage and by doing
that we found that almost in every city
almost in every city in Sweden or in
every town in Sweden there were these
areas there were a lot of people a lot
of young kids that were that were you
know criminal anyway a caveat is that we
didn't make any difference between if
they were sentenced for murder well if
they were sentenced for driving them
open too fast so I mean there's a
there's a caveat and then you have to
sort of think about that but and we also
did the gray areas here this is the city
or the town of balls are areas where
there were too few youth
to do there will only be one or two it
so we excluded them so we could see that
in every in every town we had this and
the same thing here we could do a lots
and lots and lots of stories around
Sweden by doing this if we look at
visualizations which I think some time
has taken over data journalism I think
that we should think about it both as an
analytic tool and a NASA visualization
and sometimes I think the focus of
analyst visualizations are maybe a
little too much this is a visualization
we did that I think it's quite cool it's
the whole population of Sweden divided
up by income so one percent one little
figure here is 65,000 people and in 1991
you can see that the income level of
people were very sort of put together
and if we go on to 2012 you can see that
the income levels had changed very much
and you can see that it was spread out
and also we'd had much more poor people
but also of course much more very rich
and this was an interactive tool so you
could look at the different years you
could look at females and man you could
look at young and old you can look at
the Air grop geography so you could
compare your own town with stockin for
instance and see the difference in
equity in economy there and so on
another income visualizations this is
where do I fall in the income in the
income sort of within the incomes so if
I give my own monthly income I can and I
can compare myself with females who are
47 I can see that eighty-five percent of
the females and less or more or less
than I do this is one of the favorite in
visualizations we did it is not easy but
i love that it takes a very very
complicated thing and sort of makes it
understandable this is all the schools
in stockholm and the final grade for the
school and the ninth grade so the black
line in the middle is the average for
the for the country so you can see that
there are schools that are performing
very poorly and there are schools
performing very and then we colored all
the school according to the parents and
the education level on the parents so
the green one is parents that have gone
to university and red ones are parents
that only have gone through the 99 year
obligatory school so you can see that
and I had a reporter who did the story
out this that said you know he didn't
use that as a speaker but he said that
in some schools you could put a monkey
as a teacher because it doesn't matter
because the kids that come there are so
well prepared and so by their parents
that you they just sail through without
anything and the interesting schools is
of course this school that obviously is
doing something right there lifting
their students to another level and in
some cities like mama in the south of
Sweden the pattern is even more horrible
to go back to the Guardian this is the
Guardian poll projection I know the
polls were wrong but if we for a minute
sort of think about that the fact that
if the polls have been right this is the
projection that is built on the pole so
yes the polls were wrong but when we did
this it is an interesting way of doing
this we did this all in Google
Spreadsheets so we took we collected all
the polls we calculate the average of
all the polls that's what we do here we
then looked at the votes that were cast
in 2010 we looked at the National result
that would constitute any in the in 2010
and then we made a formula that took the
polls took the swing and calculated for
each constituency what would the
Conservatives get if the polls were
right if
poles were right and then of course we
did we had to do special cases for some
places and then we did the calculation
counting all the counting all the seats
that they would get and this was done
the poles were in put it in put in their
spreadsheet every day and that's the
main reason why we use the google
spreadsheet because the poles were put
in by people who we didn't have the time
to sort of build a tool to put in all
the polls so Alberto nedeli who is the
brain boat behind this he put in the new
polls as soon as they got out and our
great visuals team programmed this Andy
Turner all wrong and a couple of more a
couple of more examples matching data is
something that always thrilled
journalists because they think that's
the coolest thing this is a story I did
about who I tried to find lobbyists in
Sweden so this is all the visits that
were done all the people that came and
visit the Swedish parliament and as you
see I got that in a in a text PDF but
let's see IOC Ardeth put it into a
database a little for trouble there but
come on oh but by doing that I didn't
find that many lobbying companies so
what I did was that I went into the
Swedish lobby companies and they are
very eager to brag about the people that
work for them because that there that's
their commodity so these are the people
that work for one of the worked for one
of the blobby and companies in Sweden
and this is Emily she works for Sun
communica phone so I had all the visits
in one table I have all the lobbyists
from the 10 biggest lobbying companies
in Sweden in another table and I connect
them in access
and by doing that I get some hits and of
course if the person has a very common
name I just I can't use that but there's
only one Emily in Sweden and I checked
and in Sweden we can check those things
so I could see that she had been there a
number of times working as a lobbyist
for the Swedish taxi Association
actually and we could do a story that
was this is influencing policy is the
story called to do this and my last
example has to do more about data
gathering actually sometimes and this I
i say this type of jaded journalism that
my my boss is a swedish television were
very fond of that it's all the Guardians
fault actually the Guardian did many
years ago The Guardian did an amazing
product where they buy a Freedom of
Information request gon hold of a half a
million paper documents or PDF documents
but picture PDFs of all the expenses for
all the mps you've you've been British
you probably heard about this project
and what the Guardian said is we can't
look at this because it's all pictures
we can't do any kind of data analysis on
this so let's build a tool and ask the
public for for help so that's what they
did this is a very now that I'm at the
Guardian i could probably get this
pictures in a better so various oh i'm
sorry it's very sort of blurry but this
is the expenses of Stephen counts and
the people helping the public when the
public helped the guarding with this
they could click on this is a non
interesting document or this is an
interesting document or this is a hell
of an interesting document investigate
this so by doing that they could get a
lot of story they could help get help to
find the stories we were a little
fascinated by this and we wanted to do
our own project and we have a TV show in
Sweden called crime of the week it's
prime time television and it's not what
you think it is you think it's something
sleazy it's run by a professor
in criminology and it talks about crime
and it's very popular and yes it's a
little Stacey something and the
professor wanted actually to find out
he's always his research has always been
looking at police performance he's not
very popular with the police force in
Sweden he's always looked at police
performance and he wanted to do to look
at what happens when you report an
everyday crime like somebody stole your
bike or somebody wrecked your car or
somebody broke in to your shed and stole
your ma la la mode not more so we went
on the air prime time and we built a
database interface they actually came to
us and said could you help us manage and
an email box sort of an extra email
could you help us to analyze if we get
on a couple of emails about this could
you help us analyze that and we said no
please don't ask people to email you
will build a database interface so we
built a database interface that's the
professor about this crime help us find
the crimes and you could then by
steering the people this is not by
steering the the for instance they had
to choose what kind of crime they had
been stealing a bike stealing a moped
stealing a motorcycle and breaking an
entry in my in my shed in my car and
that sort of thing and we also asked
them to tell us where they lived and a
little of a sort of little story about
what that what happened and we of course
also ask them for contact information
and we were very clear that this will
not we will not publish any contact
information but by doing that the first
morning when I came back came we had 800
tips in our database which is quite a
lot for Sweden I mean we're not we don't
have a big population and over the time
then we got over 3,000 tips in this
database
and the great thing about doing this as
a structured databases that was of
course that I had I had the yog raphy so
when the regional office up in north
called and said we want to do a story
out of this database this is amazing but
we want to do about we want to do about
Internet crime we want to do about
somebody who gets fraud it on the
Internet I could down just filter on the
yo graphical area and filter on the
crime and I said okay here's 12 cases
you can contact these people and see if
they want to be on television and they
had it so we got this is the blog post
we did when we had over 2,000 tips we
also could see that 7 out of 10 of the
people that contacted us but very
dissatisfied by how the police did most
of the most of the cases were folded by
the way even when people had evidence on
who did it and that sort of thing they
just folded the cases and we put the
chief of the National Chief of Police
he's not he's the guy who's not very
happy sitting in between the professor
there and we actually changed the law
they were we changed the Minister of
Justice may made the punishment for
doing petty crime or much much higher
and she also gave the police more
resources so in the end the police
actually liked us and to investigate
these kinds of things this was basically
all I had this is just a picture to
remind you that this is actually
midsummer today and this is the
essential things for Swedish midsummer
it's a maypole it's herring it
strawberries and it's a little act of it
thank you very much
we'll take a couple of questions what
I'm just going to ask in the interests
of getting the next talks ready but my
next speakers on the side rooms aeneus
and Tyler go and get set up please just
in case there are any problems behav
leads that'll be great and so we'll just
take a complement to other questions
there's a microphone yeah yeah too I
mean that's I mean that's like any I
would say like any journalism I have to
test my own series so that know the
formula was ugly it was the only way of
doing it and but of course I did a lot
of testing to make sure that I mean to I
i sometimes i calculate my formulas
manually to make sure that i get the
same result i do the calculations in
different way that's sort of necessary I
sometimes say that I treat my excel
files and databases the same way I would
treat an interview person with the same
sort of critical I I have to be the
critical in the same way and I have to
be critical of my own formulas of course
so yes I test and test again and then I
test the third time and if it's really
important I actually asked a colleague
to test question over there I can see
where's the mic for today you cost the
mic over to the the chapter that over to
the far side please obviously
yeah yeah we're always looking for new
tools I mean that is sort of that people
ask me I I as you can see in this I i
tend to use Excel a lot for sort of the
analysis but when it comes to those
kinds of things we always look for new
tools when it comes to PDFs for instance
is a pain in the you-know-what and
finding new tools to analyze and OCR
PDFs is something that we talked about
often so yes it's one last question if
you have to move on for the speakers I
think yes yeah
usually usually the last way actually
the the environment hold the omac I ramp
the story I started with that actually
started with the database because I knew
that that database existed and I wanted
to dig into that and do a story but
usually actually it's the other way
around it is a journalistic idea that
then we start thinking about what kind
of that data could we gather for that so
it's the journalism also always sort of
comes first and the methods and the data
comes second okay we'll have to finish
up there please thank